je disais et puis revenons sur la
nouvelle du jour ici ce couvre feu dr
karl weiss banani dr weiss
on va reprendre une caisse alors le
couvre feu
en quoi ça va tellement nous aider que
d'empêcher les gens de sortir entre 20h
et 5h le matin becqueter le couvre-feu
là où il a été essayée dans d'autres
pays d'afrique en l'occurrence n'a pas
fonctionné parce que les gens se
précipiter pour aller faire leurs
emplettes avant 20 heures donc les gens
se réunissaient dans des endroits que ce
soit des épiceries les supermarchés
heureusement pas dans les restaurants
ici mais lorsque s'était ouvert dans
d'autres pays
donc premièrement l'efficacité d'un
couvre-feu n'a pas été prouvé qu'en
mettant quelque chose de très efficace
ensuite comment est-ce qu'on va appliqué
ce couvre-feu qu'est ce qu'on va faire
pour pouvoir limiter la sortie des gens
comment par exemple contrôler je sais
pas moi disons entre laval et montréal
sur l'autoroute 15
toutes les voitures qui vont passer
entre 20h et 5h le matin et savoir où
est-ce qu'elles vont aller
certains vont être très justifié de se
déplacer il ya des gens qui travaillent
la nuit et des travailleurs de la santé
il ya des pompiers des policiers des
gens des mesures d'urgence des gens qui
travaillent dans des usines et des gens
qui ont des raisons aussi de se déplacer
pour toute sorte d'urgence quelconques
dont ça va être très difficile
d'appliquer de contrôler cet aspect là
on a vu aussi que les gens dépit de tout
ce qui a été fait auparavant
non pas forcément respecter les mesures
c'est pour ça qu'on en est là un petit
peu donc je vous dirais on est déjà en
confinement depuis le mois d'octobre
on a déjà des mesures en place qui sont
quand même assez sévère et restrictive
qui ont fonctionné en partie pour avoir
aplati la courbe de cette deuxième vague
mais là on est définitivement dans une
courbe d'une deuxième vague accéléré
probablement d'une troisième vague on
pourrait appeler ça ce qu on a augmenté
notre nom quelqu'un de façon importante
et en réalité ce qu'on a surtout aussi
raté au début c'est le début de la
campagne de vaccination au québec qui ce
qui doit nous sortir un petit peu du
bois parce que on voit que le nombre de
cas augmente et que les prochains mois
vont être difficiles
ok j'en viens tout de suite après sur la
vaccination mais je terminais le couvre
feu donc je vous résume docteur va s
pour vous ne seriez pas prescrits soit
mais de là du tout là vous savez c'est
une façon comme une autre de faire des
choses mais c'est difficile dans une
société comme la nôtre d'avoir un
couvre-feu avec une société qui est
démocratique impliqués comment part dans
certains pays où comme dans un couvre
feu avec une voix martiale
je suis certainement pas juriste je ne
prononcerai pas là-dessus mais je ne
vois pas comment on pourrait contrôler
et empêcher la circulation de tous les
québécois qui va se faire entre 20h et
5h et donc il va falloir compter sur la
bonne volonté des gens et ada même si
l'immense majorité des gens ont respecté
les consignes on navigue durant la
période des fêtes et on a vu avec les
voyages on le voit sur toutes sortes de
façon indirecte les gens se déplacent
pourquoi les camardes tant que ça encore
est un mélange de choses on est après la
période des fêtes vous savez faisant un
parallèle avec la grippe ordinaire
on sait que l'influenza augmente de
façon très importante après la période
des fêtes parce que les gens se sont
rassemblés
donc les gens se sont rassemblés
peut-être pas autant qu'on fait
habituellement mais certainement plus
que ce qui était prévu ou voulu par les
autorités sanitaires
donc ça c'est le premier point on a
aussi des gens qui finalement reviennent
de voyages qui sont peut-être aussi une
cause d'un peu de transmission
on a aussi le fait qu'il ya une
lassitude je pensais le point important
il ya une lassitude dans la population
sur toutes les mesures de contrôle et
les gens veulent à présent avoir un peu
plus de liberté et il s'aperçoit pour
certains groupes en sortant un certain
groupe d'âge comme les conséquences de
l'aco vie pour eux ne sont pas très
grandes
envoi pense entre autres aux catégories
de gens plus jeunes ces gens là n'est
sûr vont se réunir
comment vous pouvez qualifier ce soir la
situation dans les hôpitaux
prenons le grand montréal la situation
est difficile parce que là on est là
sous tension dans les hôpitaux le nombre
d'hospitalisations a beaucoup augmenté
depuis environ 2 3 semaines la pression
est beaucoup plus lourde est donc
définitivement qu'on est plus du tout
dans la dynamique dans laquelle on était
au début du mois de décembre
six nations monsieur legault audiences
soient pas cette dose est furieux contre
monsieur trudeau on a vacciné 35000
personnes on a vu le chiffre 2 secondes
à peu près est ce que vous pensez qu'on
devrait prendre toutes les doses
maintenant et vacciner le plus grand
nombre possible de gens et attendent
pour donner la deuxième dose pas écoutez
moi je pense qu'on est dans une
situation de guerre il faut vacciner le
plus vite possible aller en tournée au
québec actuellement on est des cadres
aux provinces canadiennes celle qui a
vacciné le mois par cent mille de
populations non et les provinces
canadiennes ont vacciné très peu comparé
à beaucoup d'autres endroits sur la
planète on a vacciné 6000 personnes
aujourd'hui au québec c'est une goutte
d'eau beaucoup de gens n'ont même pas
été encore vaccinés dans les services de
santé
on parle de vacciner deux cent cinquante
mille personnes depuis le dc le 8
février le 8 février ça fera
pratiquement de moins que la campagne de
vaccination aura débuté deux cent
cinquante mille personnes ces trois pour
cent de la population du québec donc
l'impact risque d'être extrêmement
limités par rapport à ça la seule chose
que je vous dirais c'est que qu'on est
juste l'exemple des ch et celle d'il ya
à peu près 40 mille personnes des chsct
dans les sachets celle des au québec on
aurait dû vacciner ces gens-là ans dans
deux trois jours pas plus alors moi mais
moi j'ai pas encore été vaccinés et
louis sur une liste d'attenté
alors c'est très varié il y en a qui
vont un peu mieux et y en a qui vont
vraiment mal et est donc on voit que il
n'y a pas de stratégie et massive
il n'y a pas de déploiement massif oui
on devrait avoir plus de doses du
gouvernement fédéral bien sûr mais on a
quand même donné 88 millions au québec
qui on en a administré seulement 39 bis
fait vous n'êtes pas satisfait dr va
être delà du déploiement de la
vaccination au québec pour l'instant pas
du tout mais pas du tout surtout si on
se compare à ce qui a été fait dans
d'autres pays
je pense qu'on écoute et au québec on a
à peu près 1.7 million personnes qui ont
plus de 70 ans ou qui sont des
travailleurs de la santé
ce sont les groupes prioritaires alors
si on doit protéger ces groupes là parce
que tout ce qu'on fait actuellement il
faut le savoir c'est pour une seule et
unique raison le confinement le
couvre-feu
tout ça est fait pour une raison
protéger le
système de santé ne pas être dépassé
dans le système de santé donc on protège
les gens qui vont être malade pourra
hospitalisés ou qui peuvent décédé et
les travailleurs de la santé qui vont
s'en occuper
ça c'est un point 7 millions de
personnes au québec on parle même pas de
donner une deuxième dose à ces gens là
on parle de leur donner seulement une
dose mais vous vous imaginez que si on
donne six mille doses par jour pour
vacciner 1.7 million de personnes ça va
prendre beaucoup beaucoup de temps et
chaque semaine ou en fer en efficacité
en vaccination
on va probablement payer au moins deux
semaines d'allongement du confinement ou
de la conséquence de cette vague là
parce que ces deux semaines pour avoir
une immunité
lorsqu'on reçoit notre première dose de
vaccin donc c'est clair actuellement la
campagne de vaccination n'est pas là où
elle devrait
et c'est dommage parce qu'on a les
capacités au québec de faire beaucoup
mieux et on a les gens qui sont capables
de vacciner on a une certaine expérience
avec le h1n1
on a une certaine logistique il ok là on
n'a pas d' excuses
la campagne de vaccination depuis le
mois de mars 2020 on sait qu'on espère
qu'on aura un vaccin donc on devrait
avoir un vaccin là on la sait pas il
fallait préparer il faut se préparer et
moi je pense que c'est là où il faut
miser de façon importante pour améliorer
les choses très clair dr weiss
merci il faut le dire il faut attendre
ça avait bonne année quand même on se
reparle très bientôt
merci une année puis il faut garder
notre cohésion sociale c'est important
oui